Determining the probability that a child will inherit
a particular trait is what genetic counselors do for
a living. And sometimes all they have to rely
on, is pedigree information. This is tricky business. This
means they've got to calculate probability over multiple
generations without knowing the genotypes for sure of everybody.
But only knowing whether or not a trait was
present in a family. For example take a look
at this pedigree here, it represents an autosomal recessive inheritance
pattern. What is the probability that these two people indicated
by the arrows, will have an effected child for this
particular trait? Now I'm not going to give you options
for this question. This is going to be tricky and possibly
really hard for you to come up with. But I
want you to see what it's like a little bit
to try to do the job of a genetic counselor.
Calculating probabilities from a limited amount of
information. I want you to feel comfortable putting
in a percentage, a decimal, or a fraction,
whatever answer you can come up with. Remember,
you're probably going to have to think backwards about.
Whose genotype is what, based on the phenotypic
information that you have in front of you. Go ahead and give it your best shot.